the story in Diablo 4 will appeal to
both new players and hardcore Diablo
fans and when writing this next chapter
we really wanted to return to our darker
roots sanctuary's in a very interesting
state right now it's 50 years after
Reaper of Souls from Diablo 3 where half
of the population was exterminated by an
archangel the world has seen quite a bit
of changes quite a bit of scarring from
its wounds that have not totally healed
in these years of death and decimation
power vacuums have opened up and been
filled by various factions you'll
actually get to interact with in Diablo
4. Heroes of the past that we've known
love have long since faded into memory
as well as an iconic order known as
liquor Roger the world is a bit broken
and wounded and it's in this fragile
state that inarias and Lilith's return
and they are the makers of sanctuary and
their return may not mean the best for
Humanity
before Sanctuary was created the heavens
and the hells were battling each other
in a Non-Stop War our Sanctuary was
created by disenfranchised Rebel angels
and demons that wanted out they didn't
want to be a part of this never-ending
War because there was literally no point
two of those people were anarius and
Lilith Lilith is a demon and anarius is
an angel they were part of the Eternal
conflict between Heaven and Hell in
which they were constantly fighting with
each other when Lilith captured inarias
she was ready to torture him but when
she learned that they're of like mind
she became his partner in crime they
stole a singular most important object
known as the world Stone a massive
iconic mountain-sized gem that has the
ability of creation anarius and Lilith
helped to create the world of sanctuary
and that's where the name of the world
comes from it was their Sanctuary to
hide away from the Eternal conflict they
both have similar goals
and as a demon have different ways of
going about it inevitably it wasn't
going to last they've clashed multiple
times throughout the history of the
Diablo universe
the last time they met inario's banished
Lilith from the world and blocked her in
this Realm of Darkness we wouldn't see
Lilith again until the Cinematic by
three they come when a mysterious figure
pulled her back into sanctuary and set
her loose on the world she helped create
Denarius also suffered when the heavens
found out where he was and what he had
done that he had created this world he
was punished and handed over to the
burning Hells as a peace offering
because of these two experiences both
Lilith and anarius do share that they
were betrayed and they've been
disillusioned that does not mean that
they get along there's this rare moment
in time where inarias and Lilith are
back on the world it is them fighting
each other with Humanity as their
Battleground
when the story of Diablo 4 begins this
Wanderer is trudging through the
snowstorm in a place called The
fractured Peaks really they're just
looking for some shelter the player
character in Diablo Flores whoever the
player wants to be are they running from
something are they running to something
what kind of a person are they we leave
that up to them to decide they are
seeking Refuge from this blistering cold
that is saturates everything within the
fractured Peaks they find a cave and it
is that moment where they're pulled into
the bigger events of sanctuary these
Monumental moments that will be taking
place that will shape and shake the
world
it has been 50 years since meldale the
aspect of death called about 50 percent
of humanity humans struggled to survive
in that 50-year Gap after that massive
culling the humanity itself is trapped
between the High Heavens and the burning
Hells and each are trying to influence
Humanity in their own way the players
asked to save Sanctuary by a specific
character that we actually remember from
Reaper of Souls his name is lorath narr
florath in Diablo 4 is not the same
lorath from Diablo 3 Reaper of Souls
he's a changed man he was a member of
the haradrum and the haradrum is this
secretive order of Scholars and mages
who protect the world from demons and
other Supernatural threats morath is
much older and weathered from the things
that he's seen he is struggling with who
he is with the herodrum and even without
the herodrum when lorat learns that the
player's interactions with a being that
he remembers very well he pulls them
into this mission to stop Lilith they
will need to try to figure out a way to
survive in the world of sanctuary in all
of its turmoil since Lilith has come
back
we have a lot of new characters that
you'll be experiencing in the world of
sanctuary one of them is Brava she leads
the Cathedral of Lights the Cathedral of
light is a militaristic faction led by
an RS
nres is the ultimate supreme leader but
she handles the day-to-day she acts as a
bridge between inarias and the other
followers of the Cathedral of light she
was at Rock Bottom when anarius met her
as you can imagine on Sanctuary life is
brutal anarius uplifted her and taught
her the tenets of the Cathedral of light
ever since then she's become his most
loyal fervent follower she would do
anything for him and she just really
believes in what he stands for NRS is in
various states of bitterness you're
seeing a faction that has done as much
could as necessarily bad you as a player
get to decide how you feel about those
actions and Prada will be at the
Forefront of all of it Donan one of the
herodrum he is this very gifted Mage who
also is a scholar we find him in this
place called Scots Glen where he's made
a name for himself and become something
of a hero in Diablo 4 we'll find out
what donan's relationship with lorath is
and the herodram and and how he became a
hero in this place
is this young Adventurer she has
traveled the world with her mother
looking for lost artifacts she's spent
her life going through old ruins and
reading old texts and learning these
Arcane things together they're searching
for the remnants of the haradrum they
believe in finding that they'll find
some purpose she is someone who is very
intent on stopping Lilith so she becomes
a very strong Ally for you and for Laura
throughout the game it's through her
actions that Laura and the group that
you will follow will come to contend
against Lilith something that we tried
to do from a narrative perspective is
create people that are living in a very
dark place but still trying their best
to live they'll have some scars but they
also have these
pieces of
view Humanity we wanted to ground them
in the circumstances of the world and
make them feel real and relatable with
Diablo 4 you're very much watching a
tragedy unfold it's definitely a story
that we wanted to create around people
not just the apocalyptic elements that
surround the story and that's something
that we really sought to bring to you as
a part of the Diablo narrative Lilith is
free she has some followers and she's
back on her old business she's going to
corrupt us or try to turn us to her side
for her own ads the story of Lilith and
inarias is the darkest story we've ever
told and it expands the Mythos of
sanctuary and the lore of the series
like never before